yesterday wizard entered New York with a  case full of magical creatures alright  then let's see the little guy Lego  dimensions fantastic piece story pack is  here with six hair-raising levels  amazing new worlds mumbling occasional  useful sidekicks massive cinematic  stories unexpected crossovers maniacal  villains plot twists and memorable  characters what was that brand new Lego  gateway and exclusive character and  accessory a thrilling battle arena and  an action-packed adventure world  lego dimensions story packs the biggest  thing since lego dimensions you're gonna  need an even bigger imagination